D
AND THE AIR.
>>aura: THANK YOU.
AND NOW BIDEN'S NEW LOCKDOWNS?
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
ARE WE ABOUT TO FACE ANOTHER
LOCKDO?
ANOTHER PERIOD OF TIME WHERE
AMERICANS FEEL LE THEY CAN'T
TRAVEL, THEY CAN'T GO TO WORK OR
SEE FAMILY.
NOT TO TRAVEL FOR PLEASURE FOR
ANYWAY, ONLY FOR POTENTIAL
ACTIVITIES.
TWO YEARS AGO, COVID LOCKDOW,
THE SCHOOL CLOSURES THAT HAD
ZERO BASIS IN SCICE.
TODAIT'S NOT A VIRUS THAT MAY
KEEP US FROM JUMPING IN OUR CARS
AND GOING ANYWHERE WE WANT, IT'S
HIGH GAS PRICES AND INFLATION
CAUSED BY JOE DEN'S SUICIDAL
AGENDA.
LIKE WITH COVID, TY'RE ASKING
TO SACRIFICE FORHE GREATER
OD TO.
>> AMERICANS AGREE, THEY ARE
WILLING TO SACRICE THEMSELVES
BY PAYING MORE ATHE PUMP.
>> THEY ARE OKAY PAYING HIGHER
PRICES IF IT MEANS HOLDING
RUSSIA ACCOUNTABLE.
PEOPLE AT THE PUMP COMMIEE
CAN'T AFFORD IT SAYIN IT'S OKAY
IF I HAVE TO PAY MORE AT THE
PU TO HELP UKRAINIANS.
>> Laura: THIS SHOULD BE NO
SURPRISE TO NES, BECAUSE FORDECE
ASKING HARDWORKING AMERICANS TO
SACRIFICFOR POLITICIANS AWFUL
POLICIES.
SACRIFICE FOR WARS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST, SACRICEECAUSE
OF THE HOUSINGRISIS, SACRIFICE
BECAUSOF THE PANDEMIC AND NOW
THEY ARE TOLD TO SACRIFICE FOR
UKRAINE AN CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE RESULT IS ALWAYS THE SAME,
THE GOVERNMENT GETS BIGGER AND
SPENDS MORE WHILE THE MIDDLECLAR
DESPONDENT THATHEY WERE
BEFORE.
I'M OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER WHEN
DEMOCRATS USED TO BELIEVE IN
THINGS CALLED HOPE AND CHANGE.
THEY DROPPED A THAT.
WITH DEMOCRATS ALL THEY HAVE
DONE TO DERAIL AMERICA, BIDEN'S
LONG, DARK WINTER IS TURNING
INTO A PAINFUL SPRING.
HE'S GOING TO BRING US A
SWELTERING, MISERABLE SUMMER AND
LORD KNOWS HOW TO PRESSN THE
FALL IS GOING TO BE.
>> THIS WAR BY PUTIN IS NOT
GOING TO BE PAINLES
>> IT'S ALSO TRUE THAT THE WORLD
NEEDS TO BE PREPARED FOR A VERY
LONGIFFICULT ROAD AHEAD TO.
>> THERE WILLE COSTS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
Laura: YOU KNOW WHAT THE
TRUTH IS?
THEY BELVE THE PLANET CANNOT
SUSTAIN YOUR STANDARD OF LIVING
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY THAT YOUDOF
LIVING.
THEY THINK IT'S HIGHIME YOU,
YOURIDS, YOUR GRANDKIDS GET
USED TO LIVINGITH LESS.
THIS IS ALL A RERUN OF T
1970s WHEN WE WER TOLD WE
HAVE TO DRIVE MORE SLOWLY, WE
HAVE TO TURN OUR THERMOSTATS
DO IN THE WINTER AND UP IN TSUM.
BACK THE JIMMY CARTER BLAMED
THE ENERGY PRICES BUT REMEMBER
THERE WAS NO ENERGY CRISIS, W
HAD PLENTY OF ENERGY IN THE
70s JUST LIKE WE HAVE PLENTY
NOW.
THIS CRISIS IS SELF-INFLICTED,
CREATED BY LEADERS WHO SEEM TO
BE PUNISHING AMERICANS ITEAD
OF SERVING THEM.
THEY CERINLY DON'T THI THAT
PEOPLE DESERVE ANSWERS TANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS.
>> Laura: SHE'S THE ENERGY
SECRETARY AND WON'T ANSWER
QUESTIS ABOUT AMERICANS
CONCERN ON ENERGY, THINKBOUT
THAT FOR A MINUTE.
BIDEN'S PUPPET MASTERS AREOING
TO USE EVERY BIT OF RUSSIA'S
UKRAINE CRIS TO TAKE YOUR
MONEY AND YOUR FREEDOM.THIS IS H
ANOTHER MASSIVE EXPANSIONF
GOVERNMENT, I PROMISE YOU.WE ARO
SPEND $14 BILLION D THIS AND
THAT T UKRAINE?
WHO BELIEVES IT'SOING TO STOP
ERE?
AMICANS WILL ALWAYS RUSH IN TO
HELPHOSE IN NEED,HAT'S WHAT
MAKES USO GREAT, WE ARE SO
COMPASSIONATE AND SO GENEROUS, I
KNOW SO MANY OF YOU ARE, YOU ARE
DONATING RIGHT NOW.
BUT WE CANNOT LET THIS HORRIFICO
FORGET WHAT MATTERS MOST.
RESERVG THE AMERICAN WAY OF
FE.
REMEMBER WHAT THE FLIT
ATTENDANTS SAY BEFORE YOU TAKE
OFF, SECURE YOUR OWN OXYGEN MAS
BEFORE ATTEMPTING TO HELP
OTHERS?
IF THE LEFT HOPES THAT AMERICANS
GIVE UP AND GIVE IN AND EXCEPT A
LOWER STDARD OF LIVING, THE
HIGH PRICES -- IT'S GOING TO BE
THE NEW NORMAL.
IT'S THE COST OF PROGRESS.
IT'S A NEW WAY O VIRTUE
SIGNALING, LIVING WITH LESS.
SOMETIME NOT HAVING CHILDREN,
WHAT AM I TALKING ABOUT?
RAYMOND ARROYO WENT OUT TO TALK
WITH FOLKS IN VIRGINIA TODAY
FACING HIGH GAS PRICES THEY ARE.
UP WE WILL SHOW YOU MORE ABOUT
THIS LATER BUT LISTEN TO THIS.
>> I'M GRATEFUL I CAN WORK FROM
HOME.
I HAVE SOME FRIENDS WHO ARE
SEEING IF THEIR JOB WILL LET
THEM WORK FROM HOME A COUPLE
MORE DAYS A WEEK, IF NOTUST TO
FIGURE OUT THOSE NUMBERS.
I'M GRATEFUL I DON'T HAVKIDS
SO CHANGES LIKE THIS -- THE
MARGAL CHANGE DOESN'T AFFECT
ME SO MUCH.
>> Laura: WEARING THE MASK
OUTSIDE IS ALWAYS A TELL.
THIS IS CALLED CONDITIONING,
PREMINGER TO BELIEVE TT THE
OLD WAY, KIDS, GETTI A NEW CAR
AND DRIVING WHEREVER YOU WANT,
THAT WAS THE WRONG WAY, YOU
SELFISH RSON.
IF YOU ARERULY COMPASSIONATE
YOU WILL TOLERATE AND EVEN LIKE
HI GAS PRICES.
CAUSE I WILL HELP THE
UKRAINIANS.
>> THERE IS AN UNDERSTANDING
THAT THIS IS A SMALL PRICE TO
PAY.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S GOING ON
IN UKRAINE AND YOU PUT YOURSELF
INHEIR SHOES, THAT IS THE COST
OF DEFENDING FREEDOM.
>> Laura: THEY WANT YOU T
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS ALL
INEVITABLE.THE TRUTH IS, IT ISNF
IT EVER WAS.
THREE YRS AGO, WE HAD A
PRESIDENT IN POWER WHO SHOWED US
THAT BILL AMERICA IS NOT
CONFINED TO INEVIBLE DECLINE.
WAGES WERE RISING AND SO WAS
OPTIMISM.
BUT THE GLOBALISTS HATED THAT,
THEY HATED WAGES WERE GOING UP
FOR THE BLUE-COLLAR WORKERS.
EY HAD TO DUMP TRUMP BECSE
HE SHOWED INFORMEDATIONALISM,
PATRIOTIC NATIONALISMOULD LEAD
TO MORE PROSPERITY A MORE
FREEDOM, BETTER LIVES FOR
EVERYBODY.
WHO WOULDN WANT THAT?
>> TO SHAPE OUR FUTURE IN
COLLECTIVE AND CONSTRUCTIVE.
>> CONSTRUCTION MUS BE
TRANSFORMATION.>> EVERY COUNTRY,
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION AND
COMPANY NEEDS TODOPT CREDIBLE
PLANS FOR TRANSITION TO NETERO
EMISSIONS BY 2050.
>> Laura: YOU GIVE UP YOUR
PRIVATE JET FIRST.
BIDEN IS ANSRING TO THE
PEOPLE, THE GLOBALISTS PRICKD
THE DAVOS CROWD, NOT TO YOU AND
YOUR CONCERNS.
THAT'S NOT DEMOCRACY, IT'S NOT
TH AMERICAN WAY AND THAT'S NOT
ACCEPTABLE.
THIS IS OUR COUNTRY, IT BELONGS
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, NOT
INTERNIONAL BUREAUCRATS.
THE SALARIES OF EVERY SINGLE
PERSON IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ARE PAID FOR BY
YOU AND BY KNEE.
GOING FORWARD, THE KEY ISSUE FOR
EVERY VOTER OULD BE THIS: WHO
WILL PUT YOUR INTERES FIRST?
WHO WILL WORK FOR YOU, YOUR
FAMILY, YOUR HOPES YOUR DREAMS.
WE KNOW IT'S NOT BIDEN AND THE
DEMOCRATS.
BUT IHINK THEY ARE ON THEIR
WAY OUT, THEY KNOW THAT.
THE FUTURE BELONGS TO POLITICAL
LEADERS WHO HE